winter's coming
um are you guaranteeing that the price
cap will not be tampered with abolished
or lifted during this winter i've been
very clear about this the price cap is
the biggest
uh shield uh in terms of consumer prices
and i've said repeatedly that it will
not be moved it was set in august for
the six-month period between the first
of october and the first of april
and it's not being moved and i'd like to
add uh trevor that many companies during
this period have said we should uh lift
the price cap or get rid of it and i've
been very clear that it can't be moved
because it does offer consumers
the protection that we we all need
against very very high
upswings in the price all right well and
for viewers watching thing they'd be
most concerned about can you guarantee
give us a categorical assurance that the
domestic supply will not be interrupted
i think supply is critically important
and i've always said that we have never
had a problem uh certainly in the last
uh many years actually with a security
supply and just for the
sake of the viewers it's it's important
that we look at what the elements of
supply are if you look at where our gas
is coming from where it came from last
year in 2020 50 percent of that gas was
uk continental shelf it was from the uk
30 percent was
from
norway and i spoke to the norwegian
energy minister only a couple of weeks
ago uh and they are increasing uh their
their production
uh and 20 comes from lng which is uh
around the world through through freight
uh i'm
very uh committed and convinced that we
will have full energy supply yeah but
none of those words say
you will have uninterrupted gas supplies
during this winter i'm as certain as i
could be because obviously you know this
is a global issue so we've seen right
across the world
real supply chain pressures you've seen
the chinese have power blackouts they're
rationing
supply here in the uk our job is to make
sure there's minimal disruption and i'm
very confident that there will be yeah
but you don't know do you because um you
didn't expect uh in january that you'd
be sitting here with a 250 rise uh i
don't suppose you expected that uh mr
putin would be playing mr putin's type
games with the uh nordstream uh gas
you just don't know do you well i i can
say that there are two things that
elements here one is obviously the
global price and i can't predict nobody
can predict that but one thing that i am
responsible for is the resilience of the
uk system and in that
i'm very confident that we will be
resilient we'll have a diversity of
gas supply as i uh described and also
within the energy mix itself the
electricity generation itself we've got
renewables uh we've got a
slice of nuclear power as well
and we've got a range of energy sources
which i think will be very resilient
okay can you give um
even that reassurance to commercial and
industrial users well as you know trevor
i spoke uh very extensively
with energy intensive users industry on
friday
we've uh already over the last few years
given lots of support
on the electricity and we're on
electricity pricing in particular power
and we're speaking constantly with them
to see if there's a way through and also
engaging treasury as well i can't
promise um anything as yet but we are
absolutely focused on solving this
problem when you say as yet does that
mean that you have gone to the treasury
to ask them
for a subsidy of some discipline no i
haven't we've already got subsidies in
place and it's very clear that you know
a lot of those are working we've
subsidized something like 2 billion
since 2013
for industry heavy energy users heavy
industry
but we are constantly as you would
expect in conversation with them to see
where
uh we can we can support well what are
you talking to treasury about i mean uh
the um
the head of uk steel says this is a
crisis production may have to be cut or
stopped what are you talking to the
treasury about to prevent that happening
so as i said on the consumer side we've
got an energy price cap and on the
industry side we do have we've had
measures where we support uh industries
heavy uh electricity users and there's
absolutely no possibility of a price cap
for industry no can you be clear about
that i'm
what i'm very clear about is that we
need to get through this situation it's
a difficult situation gas prices
electricity prices are at very high
levels right across the world and of
course i'm speaking with government
colleagues particularly in the treasury
to try and see a way through this but
the british chambers of commerce said
yesterday that every company
is in some way under threat
they
the industries want a price cap for
commercial for as you put it intensive
users why not a price cap of the same
kind as you have for domestic users as
i've said we are talking all the time
to industry about what the best way
forward is
um and clearly we recognize that this is
a global problem we've got very very
high gas prices very high electricity
prices we already have supports in place
for industries and we're looking at ways
that we can we can help industry
they are going to find this pretty
unsatisfactory really i mean 12
companies have gone out of business in
the energy sector since we have the year
nine in the last month alone the other
industries chemicals ceramics glass
are all saying that unless
somebody does something pretty soon they
will have to cut or cease productions
simply saying we're talking
is not reassuring it's important so you
you mixed up two things here the energy
suppliers are going uh some of them are
going out of business that happens every
winter by the way uh typically between
five and eight uh uh leave the market
this year as you say it's more it's been
more because of the higher gas prices uh
and we're we're winning since last month
yeah that is qualitative
and all the customers in those companies
have found new suppliers because we've
got a supply of last resort which is
actually working pretty well in relation
to
intensive users industries ceramics
chemicals the industries you've
mentioned
we are having a conversation and we're
trying to get a get away uh to resolve
this issue i can't come on your program
and say uh that we're gonna have a price
cap because we're trying to work out
what the nature of that support might be
but you're not saying no to a price cap
i'm saying that we're in conversation i
spoke to them on friday and we totally
understand
the pressures they're under and we want
to come up with solutions
here's the problem about all of this
that
pretty much everybody says that because
of the spike in gas prices you yourself
have been saying this that we are
talking about rises in prices of
maybe up to 500 pounds a year
how are people going to pay those bills
for example the 6 million people who are
on universal credit and had a 20 pound
cut this week
i know you're giving local authorities
500 million to help that yeah but
actually that works out at
80 80 85 quid a person which is less
than half the average rise in energy
cost it does not add up so there are
other supports that we're giving as well
you're quite right to mention the fact
that the chancellor announced the 500
million that's going to be dispersed
through local authorities we've also got
the warm home discount
which gives up to 140 pounds uh per per
person we also have uh the
winter fuel payments uh which are means
tested where people uh most vulnerable
people can actually get supports there
are a number of ways we can
we're looking at protecting the most
vulnerable
customers and also
the industry themselves recognize that
there is an obligation to help people on
pre-payment
meters and other vulnerable elderly
customers this winter as well so we're
doing a an awful lot focusing on how we
can support uh the most vulnerable
people in our society all right well
while you're talking and working out a
solution all the rest are you advising
people to wear another woolly jumper and
get the socks out well it's it's it's up
to people i mean it's amazing how
people's uh cold threshold can be uh
very different i mean some people feel
comfortable uh wrapped up in lots of
different clothes others uh
where where we're relatively little i
think people should be sensible i think
people should do what they feel
comfortable with
um so
what comfortable mean um
the energy minister says why don't you
turn down the thermostat a couple of
degrees i'm not saying
put on another woolly my job as an
energy minister isn't to tell people you
know what uh
how what layers how many layers of
clothing they should wear that's that's
not really my my job my job is to ensure
security of supply which i'm doing and
also to make sure that the costs the
rising costs which we see globally
are minimized and also to make sure that
we have minimal disruption that's what
i'm focused on look i'm smiling about it
but it's not completely idiotic to say
to people
a way in which you can help
to lower the risk
of
cuts and power supplies
this year this winter is to reduce your
use of energy and that means wrapping up
a bit more warmly
heating your house a tiny bit less i'm
not i'm not going down that route i
think people are perfectly sensible uh
users of energy i think people
understand what their their use is what
their need is um and i all i am
guaranteeing or
attempting to guarantee is security of
supply to make sure that we have a free
flowing
energy system and that's what we're
focused on